medical sketches are really like medical
memes just
reenacted and guess what on today's
video i'm gonna be reacting to some of
the most popular medical sketches on
youtube
excluding snl because we've done those
already linked down below but first i
have a major announcement for you
i am looking to hire another editor we
want you to join the team
all the qualifications and information
is listed down below in the description
so if you think you're right for the job
shoot me an email by the way if you get
this video to 100 000 likes
i might make a medical sketch of my own
hello patient
i'm dr edith selbern hi dr selberg
you're about to undergo an operation to
remove your appendix
just like this patient here you'll be
under anesthesia and completely
unconscious
he doesn't look unconscious actually i
am
still kind of conscious i can fix that
there we are sleepy time why is the
surgeon doing the anesthesia
there should be an anesthesiologist in
the room monitoring the patient like a
big function of having an
anesthesiologist present is the fact
that it allows the surgeon to focus on
the operation and the anesthesiologist
on the sedation of the patient making
sure that you're not giving too much
where you're slowing down the heart rate
or the breathing
here it looks like the doctor just does
everything now we make the incision
right here
why are there cracking noises why is the
mask not up
why is that happening right now oops
got a little leakage there leakage in
this case i have made the incision
bigger so we have plenty of elbow room
to scoop out all the parts of your
insides that have gone bad
like this one and this one
the salamis not even sure what this is
oh well out it goes now we'll move some
nasty
bones out of the way what bones are in
the abdomen that you're taking out when
you're doing an
appendectomy oh looks like some of these
ribs won't budge
time for the bone saw ribs the appendix
is not that high
up you're not going for the gallbladder
you're not going for the liver you're
going for the appendix
it's lower the ribs aren't in the way
they don't need to budge
and what kind of saw is that i just saw
that i just saw that you saw that pun
unintentional but still delicious we're
losing him
prefer crash cart give me 50 cc wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
first of all chest compressions chest
compressions
chest compressions if you're losing him
and you do not have a pulse
this person is no longer living and you
need to begin
cpr you don't start saying you need ccs
of anything you start doing chest
compressions even while you're running
not like that at first i thought the
cause of death was kidney failure
brought about by
untreated diabetes but then i noticed
the knife diabetes can absolutely lead
to kidney failure so can
untreated high blood pressure a lot of
people say well i don't i feel fine i
don't feel the high blood pressure so i
must be okay it's the silent killer
folks
hypertension can really wreck havoc
wreak havoc on your kidney and your
blood vessels
and your heart which can lead to a
stroke heart attack congestive heart
failure so many issues
okay time to test those reflexes
as a family medicine actor i see
pediatric patients meaning children
seeing a child for the first time is you
need to check their developmental
milestones and i remember one of the
things i was trained in my med school
training was why don't you throw a
a block like on the floor and tell the
child to retrieve it and see if they're
capable following the instructions and i
always
felt uncomfortable taking that advice
cause i'm like what am i gonna play
fetch with a child like
go get it hi i'm dr webmd so what brings
you in here today
well you're free too embarrassed to see
a real doctor you got me
what is it doc you have cancer how could
you possibly know that
oh i tell everyone they have cancer i
understand why doing this in the middle
of the night
quickly and the privacy of your home is
so appealing but the reality of the fact
is it's almost
always going to be inaccurate look don't
get me wrong webmd does a great job at
explaining a whole host of range of
conditions so that you understand when
you do get a diagnosis what you actually
have
or perhaps how to ask better questions
of your doctor slash nurse whoever
you're going to go see but a lot of
times when you do the symptom tracker
thing it just tells you you have cancer
what if i just say my shin hurts
see i told you cancer i really don't
think i have cancer well nobody ever
thinks they have cancer the symptoms can
take many different forms
such as throbbing in head
runny nose mild cough stress
why was stove burn on that list why does
stove burn mean
cancer i'm gonna write you a
prescription for 10 tips on how to have
a healthy summer
don't forget to bring a beach ball i
feel like there are
articles like that that keep getting
popped up and recommended to you
alongside the little pharma ads here and
there so this is quite accurate thus far
i really think that you should use some
xanoplex you just take a small
dab rub it on your belly enough with the
xanoplex
sorry about that they're one of my
sponsors you know what i'm leaving and
who are you gonna
see you don't have health insurance i
know everyone wants to create an ai
platform where you type in some symptoms
and it spits out a diagnosis
medicine is complicated medicine is
subjective
symptoms are subjective pain levels are
subjective
the way people understand medical
terminology is subjective so you just
need a human being there i don't see
humans
ever not taking care of humans but at
the same time
there are robots among us
[Music]
so speak to your doctor about any
symptoms that you may be having and have
a good primary care doctor the anderson
twins have shared a lung for 25 years
separating conjoined twins is the most
complicated medical procedure we will
ever perform
i've actually heard i don't know if this
is accurate i could be spreading
misinformation someone needs to fact
check me on this doing a full
head transplant could be the hardest
operation
see if that's the case this procedure
will take between 19 and 23 hours
if dr alexander will note the time we
will be all right
let's do this leroy
[Laughter]
i do understand the reference yes that's
world of warcraft
oh my god i remember and then they all
ran in and they all ended up dying
god what a throwback i used to love wow
it ate so much of my time in high school
was kind of ridiculous
okay let me ask you a few questions have
you ever uttered the phrase get off my
lawn
no okay i mean yeah i've said
but i didn't mean like old man like get
off main on i meant more like
this is my property so get off my lawn
i'm not gonna sugarcoat this for you you
have early onset grumpiness
what early onset grumpiness eog
you're gonna begin to enjoy fewer and
fewer things in your life you'd be
saying things like who are these people
who are those people that's the i mean
it's a real question the only reason you
leave the house is to see classic old
movies and even then you'll say
it had some good parts but all in all it
was fairly unusual even
you're very young to have eog your life
is going to change forever
what would be the treatment for early
onset grumpiness joy
fun therapy maybe i'm doing a little
stretch here there's
something called dysthymia in medicine
where you just in general for an
extended period of time have a low
mood like a depressed mood but you don't
have major depressive disorder where
you're just kind of down
maybe dysthymias can be nicknamed early
onset grumpiness
just putting it out there this looks
like it's like the 80s
i'm getting an 80s vibe oh why would you
hit the patient's head like that
uh still something missing there
[Music]
hmm
patient are they doing a c-section if
they are why are they not scrubbed in
why are they putting on non-sterile
gloves i have so many questions i don't
know what all this technology is this is
stuff from the 80s
i wasn't around back then i was only
born
pretty much in the last month of the 80s
can i put the tube in the baby's head
only if i can do the episiotomy okay
okay legs up
okay come in come on that's it jolly
good
come on we do not do that
i'm the husband i'm sorry only people
involved are allowed in here we do not
just invite
a peanut gallery to watch a delivery
actually nurses probably do the best job
at this at managing who comes in and out
of the room when i was a medical student
we actually
trained to first introduce ourselves to
the patient then once the patient was
comfortable with us we then introduced
ourselves to the nursing staff
to make sure that the nurse can help
teach us guide us because they know
so much more than we do at that given
moment and probably throughout their
careers as well that's the machine
that goes you see that means your baby
is still alive oh the velvet's dilating
doctor oh yes there's the head he has
four centimeters
five six centimeters light you can't
judge
the cervical dilation visually you need
to be hands-on with this exam
and actually do a digital exam from
there you can get an estimate of what
exactly the dilation is
if the baby's head is already visible
you're fully dilated you don't need four
centimeters
measurements like it doesn't make sense
and
frightening
we do not have butcher knives so what's
wrong with this
that's enough right sedate huh hi
i'm here for my annual physical i
haven't been in years because
i didn't have health insurance great
fill out this stack of paperwork that
you know none of the information for and
wait an hour after your scheduled
appointment to be seen
the reason this happens is because
medicine is unpredictable we don't know
what's gonna happen when a patient walks
into our room
sometimes patients says that their
problem is in knee and then we start
questioning them when we find out
they're having a heart attack that
literally happened to me
i'm linking that story down below it
started with foot pain became a heart
attack calling
at all i'm gonna tear this paper but i
don't know why i give it
because it's just paper that paper is
the bane of my existence
not only is it incredibly noisy
any time you do any kind of exam it's
like oh
it's everywhere but then also like as a
patient like rotates and flips and when
i'm doing
like a leg exam or a back exam or doing
some kind of omt
it wraps around the patient it ends up
like trapping them and
ripping someone elon musk we need you
solve the paper problem click here for
my most
favorite medical meme review ever like i
really like this one i think you're
gonna love it too
so click for that bad boy and a little
notice if you get this video to 100 000
likes
i might make one of my own medical
sketches and i was an a-list actor back
in my seventh grade drama club days
just saying as always stay happy and
healthy memes
you